>> YEAH.
MOERDICKHEIR
TH.
RA IC S REFORMOOAN.S DIAN LE, G.
>> Reporter: EVEUNTHE HOTTEST
DAY. I LHERSCH>> Reporte TOWN F
>> FROM THE ER
GELKER Reporter:SOUTH, THE
FRIENDLIESGEORGIA, EASIND PPFO .
♪UD TO BE AICAN NEARLYF COUNTYT
TRUMP IN THE 2020 PRESIDAL
EC>>ER AAD FIGHTER LF WRIGHTSVN
TRAIL,S QUICTI ,
GEE HAS ALWAYS PARTICIPATED IN E
DONE CAMPS FOR YOHE,
FOR FOVEAL00-PERSOTOS
IM ON.
HE'VOTEE PEOPLE I'T THINK HE'S
TE.
WINSI REAL
>> Repte
DOESN'T FEEL THE MERE
HAS DONEUGH TOHTSVILLE, SP. WHA
T PARADT PA
BLACK COMMUNITY.
or ENTH GRADEORSTACA COACON
THE STATE CHAMPIONSHIP FOOTBALL
A GOOD,
PLITD KID WHO
THLT A.>> THIS IS BUSINESEEL LI
HE'S READY.
>> HE'S NOT ADepS NC FHOAY STILB
WAER>> IOUGHT TOT WAIT
D LOOK INSIDE BEFORETO S WLK P
GIRLFRND
BO
NT
WLSU
ALLEGATIONS HE PAID FO
-GON MORE AGO,T
MAJOR D .AS REPEADLTHE RESIDENTA
CEYE SED BY H ENT IN JUNE
JERRY ALREAD HIS BALLOT LKER B
THE CAMPAI HAS TAK ON THE
CAAT.
>> HE'OD TO LK
>> ReporteHEES ABOUT IMPACT THE
FAMILY BUTGLES TCOE HE SEES
EW